I feel like such an asshole.
My daughter has become a fucking crazy theater kid.
Crazy theater kid. For her 14th birthday,
one of the gifts I got her was tickets to go see Hamilton.
And we just went the other night to go see Hamilton.
And while we were on our little mother daughter date to see Hamilton,
she was talking about the musical at school
that she's gonna try out for,
and she's so excited for it.
And we were, like,
talking about her outfit and her song,
and it was like, the whole night was musical theater. Musical theater.
She's with her dad for the next couple days,
so I mixed up the days of when her.
I mix up the days of when her audition was.
And I texted her this morning, like,
hey, honey,
you're gonna do great today.
You're gonna cook, you're gonna eat it up.
Sending her gifts, hyping her up.
She's like, mom,
trials for yesterday. And I didn't get a call back.
Oh, my god,
I feel like such an asshole.
I was like, oh,
how are you feeling? And tried to, like,
switch the conversation to just support her, but
I feel like such an asshole.